hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about how
to use punnett squares and a test cross
now remember that punnett squares are
simply diagrams they are diagrams that
help us to predict the outcome so the
different possible gamete combinations
that come in fertilization
remember that gametes are just the cells
that unite during fertilization so in
humans this is a sperm cell and an egg
cell and they are carrying different
combinations of alleles that each parent
has to give away now there are three
situations where punnett squares are
helpful these are the monohybrid cross
where they're used to track the
inheritance of alleles for one gene the
dihybrid cross used to track the alleles
for two genes and in the test cross
which we're talking about today if
you're interested in learning more about
the monohybrid cross and the dihybrid
cross see my other videos on those
topics now a test cross is useful
because as we learned about in the mono
hybrid and dihybrid cross videos there
are alleles which are dominant and
alleles that are recessive but a
dominant allele masks a recessive allele
that is the phenotype or physical
appearance of the individual will be
that the dominant phenotype as long as
they have at least one of those dominant
alleles so this leaves us with an
interesting situation sometimes you can
have an individual that is homozygous
dominant for a character or heterozygous
for a character this means that they
have two dominant alleles or one
dominant allele and one recessive allele
the problem here is that if they're
homozygous dominant or heterozygous they
look the same they have the same
phenotype a test cross is
is to determine which genotype the
individual is if they are one of these
phenotypes so let's look at an example
the method of a test cross is to cross
the unknown individual so the individual
that is either homozygous dominant or
heterozygous to cross that individual
with a homozygous recessive individual
and then you can use punnett squares to
look at the possible outcomes for
offspring from these crosses now the
homozygous recessive individual here
we're using the classic example of
Mendel pea plants in the pea plant that
Gregor Mendel worked with they could
have purple flowers which with the
dominant characteristic therefore
abbreviated as a capital P or they have
white flowers the recessive allele was
for white flowers indicated by the
lowercase P so the homozygous recessive
individual would be one with white
flowers and two recessive alleles so two
lowercase PS we will write them here so
since this individual is recessive for
the white flowers two alleles for the
recessive white flowers the recessive
allele is all that they have to give
away to their offspring
this unknown individual however maybe
they are homozygous dominant that would
be with two alleles for the dominant
alleles of two purple flower alleles or
perhaps they are heterozygous meaning
that they would have one dominant allele
and one allele
now we can use punnett squares to look
at the possible outcomes for the
offspring if our unknown individual is
homozygous dominant then all of the
offspring will get the dominant allele
and then of course they're going to get
the recessive allele from the homozygous
recessive parent this means that the
chance of the offspring being
heterozygous is 100% because all
offspring would get a dominant allele
from one parent and a recessive allele
from this homozygous recessive parent so
100% heterozygous offspring and 0%
chance of any that are showing the
recessive phenotype because none of them
none of these offspring are homozygous
recessive so all of these offspring
would be purple if the unknown
individual was homozygous dominant
meaning two purple flower alleles
now if the unknown individual is
heterozygous with the other possibility
then it could give the dominant allele
to 50% of the offspring and a recessive
allele to 50% of the offspring of course
the homozygous recessive parent is still
going to be giving away just the
recessive allele so in this case we have
50% of our offspring being heterozygous
so 50% having purple flowers and then we
have 50% of our offspring being
homozygous recessive or having white
flowers so this is how a test cross is
useful if you have an unknown individual
purple flowers but you don't know if
it's homeless
is dominant or heterozygous you can
cross it with a homozygous recessive
individual and based on the offspring
that you get if you get 100% purple
offspring then you now know the genotype
of your unknown individual if you get
50% purple offspring and 50% white
offspring you also know the genotype of
your unknown individual so that's a test
cross if you are interested in learning
about the other crosses monohybrid cross
or dihybrid cross see my videos on those
topics also if you're interested in
learning more in depth about the laws of
Mendelian inheritance so the law of
independent assortment the law of
segregation the law of dominance you can
also see my videos on those topics but
thanks for watching